[Music]
all right let's go to jared in
iowa city jay rude what's up dude
hey hey good morning doc good hey i
almost made
a subway joke and then i realized it's
not funny anymore
so good for you jared
all right how old are you man uh 36.
did you get that growing up subway jokes
uh
yeah yeah maybe last few years or so
if you'd been my friend i would have
been pretty relentless with them um but
i'm glad we're meeting now on the other
end of
jared's not that funny anymore all right
so what's up dude how can i help
uh yeah um well i've got uh
been married for six years now um
and basically i don't like it
i kinda hate being married um
it's it's it's just been a terrible
marriage uh the whole time
um we've never really gotten along it's
never been good
um we've uh found out throughout the
marriage that you know we both kind of
thought we made a mistake right after
getting married
fast forward to now we're expecting our
first child
and kind of
kind of concerned that as to how it's
going to
how this is going to affect the child
and maybe get some
some of your advice on
maybe how to uh
better the marriage and and or
not let it affect our child hmm
man you said a lot there um
congrats on having a kid and congrats on
recognizing that the way you are doing
stuff is
gonna melt that kid right yeah so when
you say
you don't like it it's never been good
when anyone says the word never i would
usually roll my eyes so
help me what never means it's never been
good what does that
i mean like it well i mean yeah
basically um
you know we got married on a saturday
and and sunday
we both thought we'd made a mistake and
uh you know monday
we thought maybe we should have gotten
an annulment kind of
yeah but that was six years ago dude
you're six years past right
right and it's it it just we don't get
along we uh
you know home is not it's not a place
where uh
uh where we want to be together anyway
you know
i mean why do y'all choose to do that
yeah it's a good question um i guess
from my perspective
i think we should be you know living
large we're both doing well
professionally
um but for six years y'all have decided
to
be miserable why have you chosen that
yeah i don't know it's been tough so i'm
asking you
like why are you choosing them
well i um i try i actually
try to wake up every day you know as a
new day
you know with an attitude of uh you know
hopefully
hopefully it'll be a better day and you
know trying to try and take steps
with her to uh uh you know
keep her happy i guess so this is all
her this is all her fault
no i wouldn't blame it on her that's not
that's not uh so answer my
answer that question brother why have
you
you got married on a saturday you woke
up on sunday and thought whoops
and then monday y'all talked about hey
we think this was a script how'd you
how long did y'all date before that
um dated about a year and a half and
then we're engaged for about a year and
a
half
yeah here's the thing it wasn't a
mistake
it wasn't y'all may have woke up on
sunday scared to death
you may have woke up on monday terrified
found yourself like on a
on a roofing job with no tools right
y'all are in the middle of something you
know what you're doing
you didn't make a mistake you all made
it a a choice after three years together
you all thought through this very very
well and now for the last six years so
you got a decade in with this person
six years you have this well we
shouldn't know well we shouldn't have
and i'm sitting here
listening to you thinking yeah i bet you
did and so then what
and so it sounds like for six years you
you guys have actively chosen to
not cultivate desire to not just turn
all the lights on and say what are we
doing let's
get mad in love with each other it's
just been like oh he's trying to keep
her happy and today's gonna probably be
a good day
like and so i'm asking you you're you're
a good professional
right you said you're successful as a
professional
sure yeah you're not dumb right are you
dumb
no yeah you're not dumb are you fun to
be around your friends like you
yeah like do you like music or sports or
things
yeah we have a good time generally so
why when it comes to your wife have you
chosen for a decade to be less than
joyful
not her why have you chosen that
yeah i uh i guess i don't
i don't think that i've chosen that as
uh i said
i tried to try to make the best of
things and
uh yeah i know do you hear that language
it's like
yeah i'm not going to have knee surgery
i'm not going to do physical therapy i'm
just going to try to limp the best i can
but you've actively chosen to not do
things to make this thing better
so let me ask you the other side why
haven't you just moved out dude why
don't you just leave
this is your one precious life
you got one and you've given a decade to
oh
just probably shouldn't like why
why don't you just move out well right
and you know we've had
uh conversations about divorce i know
listen i don't care about your
conversations why haven't you done it
um yeah i guess i i value i value the
marriage vows okay
the commitment awesome
but you don't value the human on the
other end of that commitment
and you don't value the guy who made
that commitment
you see what i'm saying kind of
if you valued you you would say
dude i want to be madly in love with you
you would say dude we are going to have
a marriage of reckless
but crazy town sex a lot
we're going to laugh like crazy we're
both going to do whatever we want
like we're going to have friends we're
going to have hospital we have people
over
we're going to choose that life we're
going to dance in the living room
we're going to go out with separate i
mean we're going to like i'm going with
my buddies you're going to hang with
your friends we're going to go do other
things right
and it's like well we made this vow so
i just resigned to can i ask you a
personal well we're asking personal
questions we're already in it
you're not attracted to her are you
oh yeah yeah she's beautiful
are you sure yes
is she attracted to you as far as i know
does she think you're dumb
i don't think so
do you hear the question the answers to
the questions
like it's y'all are in this weird
stalemate why why do you think you
made a mistake
like for six years you've been living
with this idea that we just i mean we
just made us we screwed up
well it's um you know prior prior to the
marriage
you know as far as dated and at the time
of date and engagement you know she
we you know our relationship was one way
and and
then after we got married you know it uh
it's like a
switch flipped and now it's the other
way what's the switch
um you know again
again we've talked about it a little bit
uh i don't care what you talked about
talking with me what's the switch that
flipped
she said she told me that
that that when i were married so
she doesn't have to be nice to me
anymore
[Music]
well played well so she said i got
married
and now i don't have to be nice to you
i'm going to be mean
and it affect your intimate life
probably
absolutely okay so now it's like i
gotcha so
why if you were writing a story about
your wife why would you
think that she is choosing to be
miserable
because just being not kind choosing to
not have great sex the person you're
married to
choosing to not do things with somebody
and walk around
like oh well i guess we're just like
that's a choice to be miserable why is
she choosing that
i don't know i wish i knew you have
known this woman for a decade
you've clearly had sex once cause you
got a kid coming like you know her
why is she choosing misery over joy
i i don't know that's that's probably
the
brunt of the issue okay so here's here's
the thing have you ever seen talked to
anybody you ever talked to
the council or anybody like that oh we
did the pre-marital counseling uh but
not nothing uh
well we've been married yeah that that
that worked out great huh
right yeah just a bang-up job that one
was all right so here's the deal
yeah tonight you're gonna go home
and um when she gets home
and i want you to turn all the
electronics off everybody's phone off i
want you to turn everything off
and i want you to look at your wife and
say we didn't make a mistake
we've been lying to ourselves and
talking crap for a decade now for six
years plus the three we were married
we didn't screw up we got married and
for
whatever reason not don't project this
onto her project this onto yourself
say the words i have been choosing to be
miserable
less than happy just ho humming through
life
instead of choosing to learn
desire to practice
desire i've chosen to
go and i've got one
precious life and i chose to spend it
with you
and i value you and i value me and
i want to completely from the floor
before this baby gets here
because here's the thing your baby will
absorb all his tension
all this mayhem all this chaos
and if you think it's bananas now wait
till you got a
one month old that cries all night and
then craps everywhere
right all i have to say is you're in it
now dude
and you've got one of two choices you
can run like a loser
with a leave a pregnant woman alone
and you're not gonna do that the only
other choice you have
that's not true you got two other
choices one our choice number two
is just continue living a miserable milk
toast
life and congratulations dude you're
gonna wake up and be 55 you're gonna be
overweight your knees are gonna hurt
your back's gonna hurt you're gonna have
headaches she's not gonna like you're
not gonna like her you're gonna look at
too much porn
and then you're just gonna be that guy
or you can put a stick in the ground and
say today
i am going to do whatever i have to do
whatever i have to do
to not save this marriage not me to love
you to learn to desire you
and that means you're gonna have to make
a lot of changes in your life and i want
you to invite her in this journey
and probably if she's been sharing a bed
with a dude who's like man we really
screwed up
should we just get divorced
[Music]
she's gonna go okay cool whatever dude
you're gonna have to just start making
some of these changes on your own you're
gonna have to go all in on you because
you can't change her
you can't but you can tell her i will
not give up on you and i'm gonna start
this thing from the floor up
and and here hear me dude why
why do anything other than that
to everyone listening if you're if you
have committed your life to somebody
why do anything other
then try your just damnedest to be
crazy in love why would you do anything
other than that it's insanity
it's choosing misery it's choosing lame
it's choosing
yeah oh my gosh
fight for it man you go see somebody
about low-level dysthymia you go see
somebody about
i don't know man i can't even trust
myself you go see somebody about i'm
about to be a dad
and i don't even know what i'm doing i'm
scared about it i think you all are both
scared
my guess is you both got stuff you both
got models of marriages that aren't
great
so you don't have a good picture of what
it looks like you thought it was going
to feel like this
sheet that going doesn't feel like that
and here's the thing man i promise you
if i was talking to her
she'd be telling me a story about you
and so your story is about her
just tonight enough
tonight enough enough and dude you're on
a multi-year journey this just
doesn't get fixed next week
and it's going to involve everything
from movement to your body to sleep to
exercise to changing how you eat to you
getting some friends to you go seeing a
counselor
to you guys deciding
we're gonna figure out how to love each
other recklessly we're gonna
practice desire god almighty
don't choose misery people don't
don't don't